bap bap bap okay so um so a lot of
people are asking for my advice for
couples in quarantine together
my main advice would be just prepare to
break up I'm kidding I'm kidding
Am I it's this is it this is this is
where the rubber hits the road I would
say my main advice would be to lower
your expectations for the other person's
appearance great leave we can't go to
salons we can't maintain ourselves
you're about to see some things you've
never seen before you're about to find
out who the person you're with actually
is what they actually look like you're
about to find out that that blonde you
married might be a brunette you might
find out that brunette you married went
grey six years ago you might find out
that Silver Fox you've married six years
ago has one eyebrow total we can't wax
and you're about to learn that eyebrows
when they're not waxed they grow in like
a visor you're about to see a lot of
hair that you didn't know existed
you've got to see things you've never
seen before you're about to see a
plethora of pubic hair you guys are
gonna be like what happened to that poor
Postell it's all this hair unless you're
into pubes in which case now is your
time to shine uh now it's your time it's
your run spring up you're gonna probably
learn soon that your girlfriend has a
mustache you're gonna roll over one
morning and your girl is gonna look like
one of the Super Mario Brothers and it
is your job to just appreciate the
nostalgia of it all you're about to see
your girl without makeup on it's bound
to happen and maybe she is prettier with
that makeup I'm sure she is
don't tell her that it's not gonna go
the way you think it's
go in your head never does cuz you're
gonna say it when she's wearing makeup
you're gonna be confused you're gonna
say you look so much prettier without
makeup and she's gonna have full base
and shellac caulk and grout you you
won't know and you can't afford to take
that risk right now because if you do
get it wrong it's illegal to storm out
of your house so don't take that risk
and if she does confront you about how
do I look do I look prettier without
makeup I would just proceed to the
nearest deck or balcony and just jump
off it you're about to learn about
eyelash extensions
what's an eyelash extension great
question you're about to see up close
exactly what an eyelash extension is
because if your girl has them they're
gonna start falling out and it's gonna
be alarming it's gonna be upsetting
especially if your arachnophobia because
it's gonna look like spiders are
burrowing into her eyeballs and like a
grand daddy longlegs is giving birth to
tiny grand daddy longlegs your main job
when that happens is to try to not wince
it's about to get serious I mean you're
about to find out that a lot of those
charming hobbies that your person has
are actually full-blown addictions that
porn thing you're about to find out is
pretty out of control you're gonna find
a stash of adderall it's gonna happen
we're now cleaning out closets and
organizing drawers you're gonna find
some weird and my advice to you is
to just drop it now it's not the time
let it go now it's not the time to turn
into the mom from the Basketball Diaries
just you have to let it go you're gonna
find out the person you live with is a
complete and utter stranger and that's
fine see it is like having an affair
with a new person that you've been with
for years my main advice
is wash your hands obviously stay home
but most importantly delete your cookies
go to settings preferences clear
browsing data
data where do we land on that did you
see me just look over at nobody no one's
in this room and went what is it / - no
one's here I'm alone literally
figuratively metaphorically also maybe
don't take advice from me I'm just like
one of the jockeys and Seabiscuit so
take it all with a grain of salt